est-ce que ça se peut de mettre son cœur
bah non sans cœur pas de circulation
sanguine et sans circulation sanguine
pas de vie par contre en 2017 il y a une
petite fille qui est née avec le coeur à
l'extérieur de la poitrine les médecins
sont rendus compte quand elle était
encore dans le ventre de sa mère ils ont
décidé de faire une césarienne et moins
d'une heure après sa naissance le bébé
était au bloc opératoire pour replacer
son cœur à l'intérieur de son thorax 14
mois plus tard la petite vannerop a pu
rentrer chez elle définitivement et
s'installer pour de bons dans sa chambre
le fait d'avoir le cœur en dehors du
thorax c'est une malformation
congénitale qui s'appelle une ectopie
cardiaque c'est très rare et ça peut
arriver soit comme ça de manière isolée
soit accompagné d'autres symptômes comme
dans le cas de la pentalogie de Cantrel
ce syndrome il y a une jeune russe qui
vit aux États-Unis pour suivre des soins
son cas est assez connu parce que en
2015 sa mère avait lancé une cagnotte
pour la faire opérer mais finalement on
s'est rendu compte que son cœur était
trop fragile pour supporter l'opération
du coup depuis elle vit sa vie comme ça
normalement juste qu'elle fasse
extrêmement attention de pas prendre de
coup au niveau du